[Music]
well hello there you are watching The
Press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editors of the guardian and the psalm
peppercura and Harry Cole welcome and
great to see both of you so as ever
let's take a look at the front pages
shall we starting with the Metro their
headline judge raps absent Harry as the
Duke of Sussex is admonished for not
turning up for the first day of his
phone hacking case against mirror group
newspapers
the guardian suggests a counter
offensive could be getting underway in
Ukraine
the financial times has news of a major
Cyber attack which is thought to have
compromised the personal details of
staff at British Airways boots and the
BBC
the times has an AI expert warning two
years to save the world from bio weapons
and cyber attacks
according to the I families who lost
loved ones to covid are angry that the
inquiry into how the NHS handled the
pandemic is to be delayed until after
the next election
The Daily Mail claims Labor's green
policies could cost families an extra
thousand pounds a year the Daily Mirror
continues its campaign against dangerous
dogs with a direct plea to the prime
minister
the express quotes Rishi sunak who says
more barges will help deter migrant
Crossings the star they criticizing
criticizes him rather for taking a
74-mile trip to Kent in a helicopter to
announce those anti-migration measures
but reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you listen
to our guests let's head straight to
them pebakura and Harry Cole
um and Harry should we kick off with the
guardian then Ukraine troops intensify
their front line we've heard from
President zielinski says more news to
come soon
um but of course we've been asked by the
Ukrainian military for everyone to keep
quiet so it's getting even harder to
work out what's happening on the front
line
yeah as spring turned into some of the
sort of long-awaited spring offensive
does appear to be if not beginning but
very close there's lots of activity
going on and I think probably the
biggest sign of uh of something
happening is the is the Russians have
been very noisy the Kremlin of making
all sorts of world claims that they've
blown up various tanks and captured and
killed Ukrainian soldiers completely
unverifiable
um sort of propaganda being pumped out
of the Kremlin which would suggest that
if they if it hasn't started already
then it it is uh you know they are
seeing troops are massing they're
they're expecting it to happen
imminently so things are going on the
fog of War will you know that takes a
long time to become clear but um I think
we can take it that uh the the spring
offensive for the summer offensive as it
is now
um is is underway if not imminent yeah I
mean it's going to be absolutely
fascinating to see what happens you know
suggestions today that possibly the
leopard two had been out in action you
know then that was disputed
um but what will be fascinating to see
is whether the Western training and the
Western uh heavy Weaponry Pippa will
make it will make a material difference
to what's been basically a stagland war
over the winter
yes and there's been there's 12
um Ukrainian brigades which have
benefited from Western training and
equipment and none of those have
apparently been spotted Out On Maneuvers
so far so suggesting as Harry says that
it's the preliminary uh stages to the
counter-offensive which we've all heard
so much about rather than the offensive
itself although obviously very difficult
uh to tell and I think uh we're unlikely
to get that verified by the ukrainians
it's going to be something anyway that's
that's um you know individual
reporters on the ground and independent
bodies will have to will have to make
their assessment of when that gets
underway and it's a very you know it's a
very pivotal moment really isn't it
because if this counteroffensive ends up
being successful if it ends up
liberating some of the territory which
Russia took in Ukraine and if it ends up
pushing the Russians back
um and sort of you know them being
ending up on the run then it uh it it
raises hopes of
um an earlier end to uh hostilities than
might otherwise have taken to place the
flip of that of course is that if that
uh counter-offensive uh ends in failure
then it really is condemning Ukraine to
a grim and grueling protractors struggle
against Russia and inevitably with that
will come in intensified pressure from
uh overseas to seed territory which is
obviously the last thing that that
zielinski wants to do but we're um you
know we're some way off all of that just
now we're just at the preliminary stages
so that the coming weeks as we go into
summer are going to be really you know
for all of us sitting watching what's
going to go what's going down on the
ground
um are going to be absolutely uh crucial
um in determining so that not just the
short term but the longer term future of
this conflict yes and in his nightly
address uh president zielinski praised
two specific
brigades and said that they had
skillfully decisively and efficiently
defended our positions destroying the
occupiers and most importantly moving
forward
um a suggestion there that they are now
taking offensive action even if this is
not the counter-offensive which everyone
has been talking about let's move to the
express shall we and obviously the words
we heard of uh Rishi sunak today more
barges that's the solution is it uh
Harry Daily Express thinks so
um the solution maybe I mean we should
see that was out today in Dover looking
um put his little life jacket on and
went on a boat and pointed at some
things
um Governor please that um the numbers
are down 20 on last year Nigel farage
very quickly popped up to point out that
it's actually been very windy and we had
the wettest march on record
um it was in March obviously and
actually the weather's been pretty
terrible this year so far so that could
have had a an impact on the crossings
either way but she said has pledged to
stop the boats very broad term by that
by next Christmas uh by Sorry by this
Christmas
um if he's only 20 down in six months
he's obviously going to miss that Target
um they are quite pleased however
ministers are pleased with the um sort
of number of albanians who've been
crossing over since British cynic signed
Aid a sort of deterrent scheme that
meant that albanians will be sort of uh
transferred back to Albania almost
immediately after landing here however
only 1800 of them have um actually been
that deported so far
um so I think there's more of a sort of
holding position really for the
government
um today they've announced a few more
barges the first barge which will host
500 migrants isn't actually even up and
running yet but they have signed
contracts I think with two more
um really I think they're in a sort of
holding pattern on migration until the
court of appeal come back later this
month is expected on Rwanda and I think
we'll see you know either you know
either heads to the Supreme Court or
there's a possibility that flights could
get going later this year
um so I think that's more of a sort of
halfway house for the government rather
than anything really tangible today
yeah um some more facts and figures from
him and confirming what we already knew
172 000 people are still waiting in this
enormous backlog that's up 57 from a
year earlier uh the highest figure since
comparable records began in 2010 but
down 17 000 and praising the fact that
what some 1800 albanians had been sent
back home doesn't actually seem a lot
does it pepper
no and I mean I think the figures if you
I think quite a helpful way of looking
at them in terms of how long it would
take to get down the backlog which is
obviously you know ultimately key to
dealing with this island processing
backlog is key to which isn't like
delivering on his promise to to uh stop
the boats uh you know obviously if you
process people faster move them on
return them or give them or grant them
Asylum then
um then you know he could go somewhere
to saying that he's delivered on that
pledge
um and the figures that I found quite
useful to look at are um that uh last
month there was uh two and a half
thousand decisions made on Legacy
backlog uh Asylum backlog cases that's a
thousand fewer than the month before but
um the refugee Council says that 10 500
so not the 2500 we've had but 10 500
would need to be made a month for
um for synac to deliver on that pledge
that's you know five-fold increase on
where they are at the moment there's a
real problems obviously there's been
some attempts to appoint more
officials to speed up the processing but
there's not just it's not just about the
system itself it's about where you end
where people end up and that's of course
comes back to the the barges and the the
large vessels which um confirmed there'd
be two more of today are understanding
that the guardian is that one of them is
going to be in T side and one is going
to be in docks near Liverpool it's going
to be a cruise ship rather than a barge
and also discussions are going on with
four other ports across the UK Newcastle
Harwich felixstowe and Royal London
docks
um to to uh for vessels to be murdered
at those sites as well but you know
those discussions are just at the early
stages and nothing has been signed yet
even on the on the Liverpool and T side
ones so you know there's no sign of that
happening anytime soon and all the while
the clock ticks down to the deadline
first it's an active delivered on his
Pledge yes and the conservative MP
Richard Drax you know pushing back on
the uh on the you know near his
constituency
um suggesting that it's going to be
interforce within a fortnight you know
worrying about the free time people are
getting you know how sanitary it is how
many people will be put into what are
they cabins are they cells who knows on
these uh vessels the times they're
reporting that French are now stopping
half of the boat migrants after this
nearly 500 million pound deal Harry so
just talk us through the uh the latest
on those two elements
yeah so there was obviously a feeling of
uh well it's kind of disquiet in the
home office in Border force that the the
French weren't really taking this
seriously obviously they've got their
own migration problems on their southern
border their their land borders as well
with the rest of Europe
um and uh obviously that came under some
heat too when he he signed yet another
big check to France to say look come on
there's going to be joint patrols and
and Joint intelligence sharing and
drones and all this snappiness
um on the French business but it does it
appear perhaps to be working
um so yeah slightly slightly more
migrants were sort of stopped from
launching on the on the Norman on the on
the French northern coast uh that have
reached the UK so far this year if that
holds up I wonder how long it will be
before Paris comes asking for a bit more
Dosh
meantime Daily Star picking up on the
fact that it was a helicopter trip for
the 74 mile uh journey to Dover for the
PM pepper
yes um an hour-long journey by train
although I when we were tweeting about
this earlier and some people were
suggesting that if anybody had had to
rely on the train services to south of
England they might understand why he'd
used to why he'd used a um a helicopter
however more seriously
um it again raises questions about
um whether he is you know in touch with
the rest of us I can't think of a prime
minister that used for official business
on taxpayer-funded uh visits a
helicopter as much as Rishi Sinex seems
to have done in the last few months
every other week he's uh he's he's
landing on the you know in Southampton
and
um you know other parts of the UK other
parts of England are traveling via
helicopter and number 10 uh argue that
it's about making the most of the prime
minister's time well you know I managed
to work on trains 99.999 of the rest of
the country managed to work on trains
um I'm not convinced necessarily that an
hour-long trip by train is something
that he can justify avoid
um by and taking helicopter instead
which I'm afraid just really gives
ammunition to his enemies who suggests
that he's out of touch and he's he's too
used to sort of a you know a rich
a wealthy lifestyle that that's you know
Harry or myself for any of our readers
so I wouldn't be able to wouldn't be
able to um wouldn't be able to emulate
and how is there shaking his head he's
probably going to tell us that uh we
should be prime minister's prerogative
any form of Transport you want even if
it's a campaign for your private jet
flights this is such a bubble story it's
so tedious the public do not care
they're actually look it's like such
sort of backward Little Britain sort of
skepticism look at the way that every
other European leader travels around
look at the way the American president
travels around look at their entourages
we've all had this sort of hair shirt
I'll remind you of that when prime
minister Kirsten
I actually just I actually just Google
something and I'm going to read you
something from I can read you something
from May 15 2007 in the Daily Express
written by Mesa Hall uh our former
colleague and it says Blair swans around
in helicopter prime minister spend 50
000 pounds traveling in a Royal Navy
Merlin helicopter to visit Three schools
this isn't new and it's just so tedious
and you know what I'd like to see kirst
armor flying on an helicopter because
that's what prime ministers do okay I
feel hole coming on don't you anyway
both of you stay there lots more to fit
into the next part of our program
including our Prince Harry being
admonished today for not turning up to
the opening day of his phone hacking
trial we will discuss that and more
after the break
[Music]
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me now papakura and
Harry Cole to discuss more of the papers
for she checks the date Tuesday I think
I never I can never work it out anyway
let's go to the metro and a number of
other newspapers obviously Pippa that
are leading on Prince Harry's appearance
in court it will be on Tuesday and the
first time a Rolls appeared as a
claimant so a very interesting day at
the high court ahead for all of us
yes and uh we're expecting initially
Prince Harry to be uh in court today but
he took the decision to be uh to stay in
California for his daughter's second
birthday and to travel out uh on Sunday
overnight on Sunday was apparently still
suffering from jet lag today so so it
didn't appear in court and was
admonished by the judge and you know it
strikes me that given that this is a
civil court where there is no jury to
appeal to
um it isn't necessarily the wisest of
decisions to annoy um the one person
who's going to be making a ruling
um in your case
um but it's um it's going to be an
interesting day when it finally you know
an interesting time when it finally
happened
um because Harry will of course be the
first Royal since uh 1891 when Edward VI
was interviewed about
um in the was being interviewed in court
about an alleged cheating in a card game
um and uh certainly these days we've a
lot more there's a lot more cameras and
and journalists and TV Crews and all the
rest of it is going to be a major
um a major Royal and news event
um so I think we'll we'll have be
hearing plenty about it in the next 24
hours as Harry uh tries to bring his uh
claim against
um the mirror group newspapers and they
in turn try to cast out on his evidence
and his motives bringing the case so
we've got all that ahead yes and plowing
through all the different articles that
he says were obtained by illegal means I
think originally it was more than 100
it's been honed down to 33 of which 12
discussed his relationship with Chelsea
Davey the suggestion has been made by
his team you know that effectively broke
up their relationship and this is all
about the damage that is done you know
as people worry about you know who's
been giving information about them
um and the guardian amongst other papers
pointing out that the phone of Diana
Princess of Wales was allegedly hacked
to try to obtain details about her
meetings with Michael Barrymore so it
looks like he'll bring in his mother as
well into this Harry but you know the
whole point is the importance for him of
having his day in court I suppose isn't
it
yeah I mean the the way these things
work is he gets to say a huge amount of
things you know ahead of the trial in in
submitted to the trial that you know get
thrown out there without any sort of
scrutin in it we're now going to see the
other side of this of this argument and
it's gonna be interesting for Harry I
think and then you know as Pippin
pointed out you don't you don't really
annoy the one person that's gonna be
making these decisions and winding up
the judge on day one not a great start
but all the time we've heard from Harry
in the last year or two years or so it's
been soft soap interviews with Tom
Bradbury soft soap interviews with with
Oprah you know the the puff Piece book
ghost written by someone else you know
the Netflix completely unchallenging you
know witterings from the pair of them
without anyone actually actually
fighting back and actually arguing an
alternative view so I wonder whether
actually you know this is the wisest
course of action for Harry and whether
he realizes actually that it's not just
going to be the Harry show he can't just
swan in from LA on his jet whenever he
wants to and turn up when he feels as I
get you know he's you know he's taken
this this course of action and he's
going to have to defend you know what
you know what is what is what is alleged
so it's going to be um I suspect quite
quite spicy okay yep full coverage
obviously
um now to the times uh the most sobering
story possibly uh that we have here
um the news that AI systems will be
powerful enough to kill many humans
within wait for it two years uh this is
Rishi sunak's advisor on artificial
intelligence
um yes Peppa
right well I'm not professing to be an
expert on artificial intelligence here
but I have to say
um if we all end up getting taken out by
computers in two years time then
um well maybe I shouldn't dismiss it
maybe I shouldn't dismiss it it just
seems a bit overstated to me I know that
there's a huge amount of concern in
Whitehall and government at the moment
that we don't necessarily have the
legislation or the tools generally to
equip us to control to limit
um to restrain artificial intelligence
and that we are playing a bit of a
catch-up game with all of that but the
focus is very much on it now and I think
actually that our biggest concern when
it comes to AI in the short term and
maybe you know longer term there are
going to be problems with uh by weapons
and Cyber attack vets from AI but I
think our biggest issue in the short
term is uh is one of disinformation and
I think we're likely to see that in
particularly the elections in the United
States next year we're already seeing AI
being used to create videos and
um and information which is being shared
and even if those uh individuals even if
it's made they're made aware that that
the um those particular
um items are not you know are artificial
and have been generated by computers
rather than capturing what's already
going on they nevertheless become a
talking point yep apologies to uh to
step in there run out of time